so my name is ret manir I am a faculty
member in uh engineering at e and we
designed computer chips uh this is a
quite a big departure from some of the
topics we've heard from before and uh
normally if I gave a talk that had
inference in its title people would be
wondering what AI Hardware I was
designing uh but that's not what I'm
going to be talking about today I'm view
me as a consumer of inference I have
questions about whether something I'm
doing is a good idea or not and I want
to see if that's true and how do we go
about evaluating these things in the
design of a chip so I'll give you a
little bit of background on the kind of
things that we work on just to get give
you some sense because it's quite
different but it was interesting to see
the talks this morning because I see
many commonalities and models that are
being talked about in different
disciplines so and you will probably see
figures that look familiar to you from
the talks we've heard earlier so um so
I'm a computer engineer what does that
mean we design and build computers okay
so um and this is actually most people
think of this as a very you know
formulaic process but I would argue this
is actually you know I would argue it's
more like art uh rather than um science
because you're are coming up it's a
creative process you're trying to see if
something's a good idea or not and the
and this design can happen at many
different levels of abstraction and this
is kind of you'll see this as a theme on
how we try to understand if some idea we
have is a good idea or not right and you
know these abstractions go all the way
down from physics all the way down to
you know the software running on your
computer and there are diff and at every
level there are many sort of
intermediate levels this is all
subdivided to so that we can actually
manage the
complexity um and throughout um even
though most people don't do this I have
a particular bias in the way we work on
our our systems and we have mathematical
models that we can use at many different
levels of abstraction okay so I mean
these are some examples of things we do
at the end of the day we design
something that looks like you know this
picture over here uh you can just think
of it as geometry it's lots of
rectangles of different colors different
colors are different materials you're
really specifying exactly what the
manufacturer has to do to manufacture
the electronics okay so that's that's uh
the sort of things we do and these are
engineered systems right so you think I
have full control at the nanometer scale
of what every little piece is doing so
this should be easy it should be easy
for us to figure out whether this is
good or bad it's all you know I have
full control I have software I can
represent everything no problem but the
problem arises simply because um these
systems are extremely complicated um so
there are billions of components
interconnected it's actually pretty
astounding what we can make today uh
everybody takes it for granted uh we can
make systems which have billions of
components integrated at the nanometer
scale and they cost $100 right uh
otherwise you wouldn't have a cell phone
um so that's that's the kind of thing we
look at and the question
is you know this is the question I'm
trying to answer I have some idea I
think this is a good idea but is it
actually good I'm trying to answer this
question and this idea could be anything
I have a new way to do you know my
latest machine learning Hardware I have
a new way to do my my chip I have new
way to design my phone is this is this
good or not and uh this is sort of the
standard paper this my C like almost
every paper you read looks like this
okay it says we have this great idea um
we implemented the original system
without this idea and with this idea and
we got these two different numbers one
is better than the other my idea is good
right that's all the papers but you
know a lot is left unsaid and and this
is the part where it starts getting
getting interesting okay uh by the way
this happens in many disciplines I'm
just picking on mine so uh you know lot
of people don't talk about what didn't
work um and a lot more as we all know
doesn't work than does work um a lot of
people don't tell you what's bad about
what you your great idea uh in fact if
you do that you have a very good chance
your paper won't even get published
because you actually admitted that this
isn't a perfect idea
and um the the thing that is always
hidden I find it's very very rare to
find this is to say you
know this idea is only good because this
critical parameter has to have this
particular value and any uncertainty
there is going to blow it all up um you
know I had did this fun experiment when
I was teaching a class one year where we
were reading papers and as
homework I made I picked a small piece
of the paper and I asked a a group of
students students to replicate those
results that's it nothing else just and
then present the paper so they had to
present it first and then they had to
replicate the results and then represent
the paper and I can tell you that not a
single person reached the same
conclusions as the authors of any paper
we had read right and these papers are
you know famous papers by famous authors
from famous universities right it was a
very interesting the students were just
shocked right I mean we all know this is
you know I don't think anybody in this
room is surprised but anyway but I think
it was actually very helpful for the
students to understand the limitations
of what's going on so what are the
challenges for in in my uh in the sort
of the world we work on in computer
design um we have a lot of tools at our
disposal okay so I should I should admit
that up front you know this isn't as I
said it's an engineered system usually
we we're not trying to do something that
might like you know might create
controversy in of the physical laws or
anything like that we're very far away
from that um you're typically looking at
classical systems even the ones which
have Quantum effects they they have
understood models um we can run
simulations at varying levels of detail
okay but I can tell you that you know
there's depending on what level of
detail you want the execution runtime is
8 nine 10 orders of magnitude slower
okay so there's just no way you can do a
first principles
calculation to compute what you need to
know it's just not even
possible um by the way that eight ORD of
magnitude includes you know running this
on the fastest supercomputers in the
world okay so you know don't worry the
computers are faster that that's not a
problem right I always used to joke that
we bootstrap the next generation of
computers by designing faster computers
that we can then use to design the next
computer and so that's what keeps things
tractable
um mathematical models so there are lots
and lots of different mathematical
models that I used to describe uh and
I'm going to just pick one metric for
this talk which is performance how fast
does my computer run just one metric
there many others but let's just pick
one um it's challenging to capture all
the details so the good thing about a
mathematical model is it allows you to
try to capture the essence of what
you're trying to model and ignore
details but the details sometimes do
matter and then you have to sort of
figure out what what's good or what's
bad okay so uh and I hate to say this
but this is definitely true there are
actually like you know sections of
conferences devoted to models where
there's a large community that writes
hundreds of papers a year and the models
are completely wrong well they're not
wrong they just don't correspond to
reality so um and they actually never
did okay so it's very interesting but
but you can prove very nice
theorems um which is a very you know
that's why the academic Community sort
of works it and then the last thing you
can do is you can actually build the
system and see is this even good the
problem is this is a huge undertaking
okay uh just to give you some
calibration you know if you can know
these numbers when companies fail okay
so uh companies like Intel have
announced large projects that they
cancelled and you know they a $5 billion
hit on their balance sheet for one chip
right so these are extremely expensive
prop it's an extremely expensive
proposition and the problem is the
systems are
complex no one has enough space to
describe all the details to even do a
reproducible experiment right even
though it's an engineered system
somebody has a model somewhere they
don't want to tell you what it is so the
other part of this problem in this
particular domain is companies are
making a lot of money so uh they don't
actually want to tell you what they did
uh so that's a problem so there's a lot
of hidden information
um but the good news is because there's
a lot of money at stake when people
build these models and they write papers
they actually have a very good incentive
to get them right okay because if
they're wrong I mean this has actually
happened there are major companies that
went out of business because the models
they were using were wrong
okay uh happened know 10 years ago for
example so so there's good and bad but I
mean but if you look at the complexity
of the systems we're trying to model
um I'm I'm now I'm now simplifying
things a bit we've got about about 10
billion components at a you know
individual com device level by the way
that you could go you could go to the
materials and the physics I'm not even
going there okay that's even much more
complicated um and even if you get to
like the scale of a single chip in the
most simplified model you would have
about, to 10,000 components all
operating concurrently all with some
complexity in terms of the state
internal State Transitions and so on and
so forth so that's the kind of systems
we're talking
about so let me give you a very simple
example of what makes this hard and show
you sort of an example of what we the
kind of things we do to try to model
these systems so here is a simple sort
of there's a standard compute p pipeline
okay so what what is this picture trying
to show I have inputs coming in and then
there are these different steps for for
computation and the first step takes 20
units of time and then you hand over so
it's like an assembly line right you
hand over something to the next step
right it's very simple pipeline 20 units
of time for the first step 20 to the
second 10 to the 3 very straightforward
and I'm going to take two different
variants okay one where is 20 20 10 and
10201 and my idea is something that will
speed up step two
okay I can look at the second system and
say this is a great idea right things
got faster but if I apply it to the
first one nothing improved the
throughput of the system has not changed
because you're still limited by this
first step that takes 20time units and
so you think this is this is not a great
idea so just depending on which system
you're evaluating even though sort of
locally you are improving some
quantitative metric very clearly the
overall system didn't improve right and
this can get so this is the simplest
example I could think of because it's
you know easy to understand but the
networks of these pipelines that are
used to build these chips have as I said
tens of thousands if not you know
hundreds of thousands of components
they're not this simple data routing
depends on the value so for example
let's take a very simple example maybe
step one takes either 10 or 20 units of
time depending on what the input data
are
now all of a sudden this becomes a very
complicated question depends on the
context depends on what the actual
inputs might be in real life whatever
that means right um if I run a program
where it say you running a program you
might get different results so we can we
actually can have a real difference in
our evaluation of the exact same idea on
the exact same system I might think it's
good and you might think it's bad and we
are both right okay so this is the kind
of challenge that we have
right um but you can say well okay I
have this pipeline why don't we try to
analyze this I have some you know
logical description of the entire system
in some digital format okay at whatever
level of detail I I have very I actually
have the level have the description at
many many many many levels of detail
okay that's kind of how we can sort of
deal with the
complexity so why don't you just analyze
it well it turns out that if you assume
something as simple as a I can represent
integers and simple things like addition
then everything is immediately
uncomputable like you know like because
of good Al's incompleteness theorem
literally so you can't compute anything
so you can say okay well that assumes
infinite Precision arithmetic all sorts
of things so okay things are finite
State okay well I only have two to the
10 to the nine states to to compute so
it's just not attractable right so these
are the kind of things we grapple with
and so sort of what we try to work on is
how could we come up with models that
are reasonable
approximations where we can try to do
some of the things we need to do try to
answer some of the questions in terms of
evaluating
ideas um in a way that's you know
reasonable timely something that we can
actually use right and I'm going to show
you example an example of a very
simplified model that's actually useful
even though it's wrong okay uh it's an
approximation but it's it's still it's
very helpful uh and it was funny there
was a there's a picture that looks very
Sim similar to this uh earlier today uh
these are models the idea here is I've
got um I should just use
this I've got these little things here
this is B minus y up C up at the at the
lowest level well not even the lowest at
a at a reasonably low level of
abstraction I have variables in my
system that can take binary values zeros
and ones this says b went B down so B
went from one to zero it's it's an event
right that's very simple and these
arrows are trying to indicate and you
know this is cause actually we
engineered the system so we know that
we've built some physical device that
has b as an input and Y as an output and
B going down causes y to go up that's
because there a device that literally
implements this particular thing uh fun
feature so you can draw these arrows and
now I have these two arrows here going
to B+ that says I have to wait for both
of these to happen before B goes up
right so that that's the kind of system
and then this has a cycle but that's
okay because you see I've marked the
cycle uh the idea here is you unroll
this in you you label all these events
this is the first appearance of B down
or B up so you you you tag everyone
every event with an integer and so you
can unroll this graph but because
remember I'm building some physical
system that I'm modeling it turns out
you can collapse this graph into a
cyclic graph who's unfolding in is
actually the computation right that's
the
idea and then uh um so it turns out that
uh these structures have been studied
for forever including in pure
mathematics if if you're a mathematician
these are called Max plus algebras there
are lots of theorems in the field of
Dynamics and pure mathematics that
analyze these things to try to figure
out what when events occur things of
that nature
so what we can do with something like
this is we can uh come up with some
theoretical results now that I have an
abstract model that says for example the
model would say that the the time at
which y up occurs is the time at which B
down occurs plus some delay where did I
get this Delay from that's an
abstraction based on sort of the physics
of the electronics we know sort of the
time temporal relationships between sort
of those two events and we abstract that
as a number okay again this is wrong but
it's quite useful right um so that's
kind of what we do and then turns out
that even though these everything is
running in continuous time right uh
you've got millions of these things the
the graph for a normal chip would have
you know millions of you know tens of
millions of these nodes uh for at least
to get to the scale where the analysis
is useful um you'd have tens of millions
of these sort of events and you they all
have delay calculations it's actually
non-trivial to do all of this stuff um
but you can prove uh theoretical results
about the model which which then give
you a very good idea of how fast your
ship is going to run so one of the
things you can do for example is if you
say I have the time for a transition or
an event in the system the I occurrence
if I denote that by time um so you can
actually prove that the the system
eventually becomes sort of periodic but
not not fully periodic periodic at an
unfolding so what this basically says is
the time of a transition at some time at
index I M plus J is some constant plus M
* another constant time I so the so I
and J are the two variables here so you
can see that all the transitions
eventually become periodic so you can
actually prove this mathematically it's
it's not fun but you can do it it's a
long proof uh it turns out that there
are simplified versions of these graphs
like actually the one here where it's I
can Pro I prove this in like 15 minutes
in my class to undergraduates I can do
that but as soon as you start removing
the restrictions and getting these
graphs to correspond to to circuits that
you build um the proof is a lot more
complicated but it we we actually worked
this out not too long ago so that's the
sort of thing we do and then what what
we can then do is now that we have a
mathematical formula for what we know
the system is going to look like in the
stady state I can figure out how fast
things are going to run when every event
happens and I can now write software to
take something that only has a million
in you know vertices and edges and tell
me how fast my Chip is going to run
okay and this is actually pretty
tractable so you can actually do this we
have software that does this you know
it's in the public domain um that's the
kind of thing we do for you know to try
to figure out how fast the system is
going to run but again you know this is
an approximation okay a very simple
change you can do to this is for example
B going down the time at which this
occurs is going to be the max of the two
possible predecessors right because you
have to wait for both of them but that
doesn't correspond to most things I
could just I could change when one of my
input changes then I would get min as
soon as I add that complexity there's an
exponential factorum that gets added to
the complexity of the algorithm that you
need okay so it's these these it's it's
actually very interesting so we the
reason we use this model is not because
it's right it's because it's it's
actually tractable right um so that's
the sort of thing we do um to design our
systems uh it turns out it's actually
quite useful in spite of
that um there's another set of things
that we do to analyze systems um and uh
it was funny that you know the the
sessions called causality here the the
technical term that's actually used in
the literature in the in our modeling
literature is actually called potential
causality okay and the reason it's
called potential causality is because
exact causality can't be computed it's
too
complicated so you have an approximation
of it that we call potential causality
and um actually we have the first
results on this as it applies to
circuits this idea is actually very old
from the ' 70s which applies to actually
distributed systems like computer
networks but we've actually got got the
equivalent idea that we use the same
words because it's basically the same
idea when we talking about individual
components of digital electronics like
signals and wires and what you can do is
very so the way you know if some there's
causality in our in this kind of
analysis is sort of interesting what we
argue is that if so this is a a timeline
uh by the way you you can never build
this timeline it's to it's too
complicated but you've got a timeline
I've got all the variables in my system
everything because I engineered it I
know every single variable not just the
inputs and outputs but all the internal
State possible and then I'm going to put
a little dot here that says the variable
changed that's all that's all that means
and so I can build a timeline a logical
timeline okay um we talk about what
everything
changed and then I can pick a particular
variable at a particular point in time
and say what caused this variable to
have this value at this time and because
I have the full topology of my
engineered system I can actually say
okay well the first thing I can tell you
is the fact that this variable was at a
particular value at this time depends on
its own history right so that's what
this horizontal gray bar is sorry the
one this one right here right the one
with X and then at this point it changed
and this change from that sort of that
previous graph came from these two other
variables having certain values so I
depend on my neighbors at that previous
point in time they depend on their own
history and so on and so forth so I can
actually build a cone of
dependencies okay that's that's kind of
how we say what what I and and this is
potential causality because I guess I
said it's an approximate approximation
right and then the reason we can we we
say that this is potential causality is
because you can now prove mathematically
in the model that
everything outside that
cone you can reorder in time there
exists an alternate
execution where this node would have
this value at this particular point in
time and everything else can be
reordered so that in fact it didn't
change even though it's actually changed
I could have had an execution where it
didn't change and therefore therefore
it's not causally dependent right so we
construct these alternate executions in
the proof to show that the reason that
the causality is limited to this cone is
because everything else could be
postponed didn't have to have happened
does it make sense so that's the kind of
sort of theory that we use to argue
about what's dependent and and again
this is an engineered system so I I
actually know all the edges right so
people are talking about systems where
we don't know what the variables are
it's a totally different world but
that's the sort of thing that we do okay
have a couple of minutes left and so I
thought just stop by talk end with just
talking about sort of the approach that
the the field takes to try to make sure
that you know the results we get with
sort of more abstract models lines up
with when you actually manufacture the
device and you know get it so by the way
just if you may not know these costs but
um to manufacture a chip costs roughly
$5 to10 million to get the first part
and then every additional one cost $50
this a very interesting economics okay
so imagine if you're writing software if
you time you hit compile you have to pay
$5 million okay so you don't do that too
often the funny thing is in spite of
that sometimes it's cheaper for people
to make the chip and test it than to run
the
simulations okay believe it or not okay
I used to always wonder why companies
wasted so much money fabricating these
chips and at some point I realized oh
yeah it's much cheaper to do that than
to pay the people to wait for the
simulation to be done that's why right
so it's a very interesting
World um so at the materials level I
mean you basically by the way all of
these things are all underpinned by
experimental data this is been
constantly gathered every I would say
every week every month throughout the
last 40 years uh companies are running
examples universities are doing research
I mean there's a huge group of people
working on this at every different level
of abstraction they collect experimental
data from materials they validate Val
that against their physics models or VI
rather the other way around right they
validate their models with the
experimental data they run numerical
simulations and make sure that they line
up once they're happy with that those
models are then used to build the next
level of abstraction so you build models
out of the previous levels that have
been validating against the lower level
physics of the
materials uh and then you build your
device individual components devices
again these are fabricated and tested
and you know all of this happens uh the
some the next level the whole discipline
of building these models is sometimes
called compact models because they're
not first principles physics
calculations they would be too slow
they're much more compact there have few
parameters uh well few thousand
parameters um again all of the numerical
simulations underpin all of this at the
lowest level of abstraction at some
point you go to you know ones and zeros
okay and at that point you switch from
Pure numerical simulation to simulations
that have delay value as real numbers
but then you you do this as an event
based model okay so you record what are
the things you know you know an input
changes that causes this output to
change so many Pico seconds later you
record that right um and then you scale
up by saying okay I now have something
that adds to numbers so now I'm going to
say an block that adds inputs and
outputs again you're you're losing
Fidelity at all of these levels of
abstraction but that's essentially how
we go about trying to figure out what's
going on so I hope I've given you a
flavor for the sorts of things we do and
um you know how we go try to make sure
that we're not wrong and by the way
we're wrong all the time I should just
just be clear
but uh and that's that's actually
partially why there's very little big
change if if you look at what's in your
phone last year versus this year the the
Delta is extremely small and the reason
is if you make a big change it's like
well I have no idea whether it's going
to work at all and no one is willing to
take the risk because you know companies
have many companies have gone out of
business by doing that so it's a it's a
very it's a sort of an interesting setup
but without that I'll
[Applause]
stop one maybe two questions
yes yeah it's a great talk um so when
you you prove something about the higher
level
model um there's kind of an additional
proof which is required which is about
the relationship between the high level
model and the lower level model correct
so it's one thing to say that you know
your high level model you know is
periodic or whatever um but the second
connection is often do you like to what
extent do you formalize that or is just
an intuition as a system designer um
that this is more or less correct to
what to what extent can that be made
systematic uh this relationship between
between the different levels right so uh
that's a great question
um
so when you switch from what so there
are two parts of the question actually I
don't know if you intended it that way
but I think there are two parts of the
question so I'll answer that are two
parts one of the levels is just going
from say materials to devices to Boolean
values there's that part of the stack
and at that part there's a pretty clear
sort of functional abstraction there
that's basically uh two in two
injections essentially that are used to
go from one repes one information
representation to the other and so those
are being crosschecked all the time so
that at that point it's very consistent
once you go from the the lowlevel
booleans all the way up to say you know
a plus to mean
addition that's no longer the case uh
for that we actually use uh actually we
actually have the first uh automated
flow to do this Believe It or Not uh see
if the paper gets accepted most likely
not um um where we we actually use a
combination of formal like formal math
like theorem proving actually use a
combination of theorem proving model
checking and something called
translation validation these are all
three ways to do formal verification we
need all three it turns out that all of
them have strengths and weaknesses and
we kind of use them appropriately where
we can we actually have an endtoend
mathematical proof from the highest
level of abstraction at which we
simulate all the way down to the zeros
and ones but that's actually like I mean
as I said the papers in submitted but
you know it'll get rejected a few times
I'm sure um but yeah but yeah that's a
great question it's it's a very hard
problem actually um but we yeah so
because what we found is the way we can
do it is because the system is
engineered we track when we are
designing the system we keep track of
side information so all of these tools
work by searching in some complex space
and this search is you know
exponentially hard but because we know
how we designed it we can constrain it
and guide it in the right way and so we
keep the side information along and then
you can actually generate a mathematical
proof I suggest we thank you very
[Applause]
much